[Music]
it's parents night out for Khloe
Kardashian and Tristan Thompson here's
the pair's stepping out at poppy
nightclub on Monday their first sighting
since returning to LA Chloe looked
incredible as she rocked a green jacket
paired with sexy thigh high boots while
Tristan kept things simple in Gucci
sweatpants and sneakers the outing comes
in the wake of Tristan's alleged
cheating scandal which went down around
the time of baby trues birth which the
couple has never publicly acknowledged a
source previously told ET Chloe was
quote doing everything in her power to
make this relationship work and that
their daughter actually brought the
couple closer together the night out
also comes after the Kardashians
welcomed Coko and baby true home from
Cleveland with the cutest decor look how
cute my girls are at my home world ain't
in for me my little baby
earlier this month Kim told et about
planning the surprise celebration for
their sisters return to the west coast
how excited me and Kylie and Khloe are
planning like one of those kids photo
shoots just like a silly shoot that we
can have all the girls cuz stormy and
Chicago have so many pictures together
so we can't wait for true to join the
crew
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]